comme vous pouvez le voir dans cette
vidéo c'est sans son bien écarter bien
rond et super héros j'adore ça les cinq
cardinaux
alors dites moi à quel point vous voulez
qu'ils soient gros je veux un bonnet d
bien plein un bond est ok mais ils ne
resteront pas comme ça la gravité vous
savez ok je pourrais le refaire et bien
sûr pas de problème tous les cinq ans
pour assurer sa super production son
aide médicale est devenu assistant
smartphones regarde ça je veux le maître
par là alors je la trappe doucement et
eelv à l'agrafer de façon temporaire
alors la jeune adolescente également de
aurélie d'autres bons vous vous
connaissez
quitus à la télé réalité qui est qu'il
arrive plus à se passer de la chirurgie
franchement allez vas y à divide erton
large plus qu'un personnage et parce
qu'elle peut refaire de plus mais pour
l'instant balcou et des couacs où le
décor est alors je leur fais les fesses
j'ai pris dix kilos
on m'a enlevé tout la grèce qui se
trouvait ici pour me venger kt et dans
les fesses et j'ai aussi mis des
prothèses mammaires
en gros j'ai fait tous corps il ya du
matos voilà je suis belle voiture matos
et j'ai envie qu'on me retire des boules
de bichat ici et si j'ai une basse
sainte-catherine et j'ai envie de le
faire j'avais complètement barge la
pointe de mon nez et un petit peu trop
long le sang coule c'est tellement
simple maintenant d'aller se faire une
chirurgie j'ai l'impression que c'est
comme si on allait chercher du pain chez
le boulanger liste s'est allongée
chez le boulanger ah oui excusez moi je
refais le corps mais pas le cerveau oui
c'est qu'ils exploitent le chirurgien
alors on aurait pu donner ma demande et
à la semaine aurélie d'autres mon
oreiller d'avoir 27 ans tuypens
attention elle et c'est une jeune fille
qui déjà moi je la trouve très jolie
on dirait pas du tout une fille hyper
refaite c'est pas du tout vulgaire et
franchement c'est assez naturel
maintenant c'est une fille qualifie les
parisiens mes godasses au soir rebondi
quand même payer la ville vrai et si
agréable mieux qu une personne vous avez
une vraie souffrance et qui grâce à ça
et se sentir mieux dans sa peau
aujourd'hui ça l'aide je pense
aujourd'hui c'est si elle elle a vécu
pas mal été joués aujourd'hui tu voit
bien qu'elle est complètement épanoui
qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
n'avait pas démissionné en bloc avec un
genre d asnières rhodanienne qui dit il
exploite la bêtise cet univers verte
herman je parlais en général quand tu
vois cette personne et que tu dis allez
y les expats l'appétit et voulant
regagner leur logis c'est pas un jeu on
va garder mais là je voyais ce que vous
avez déjà euros qu'on recourt à la
chirurgie oui je pense que ça les fait
rire alors étonné moi je pose la
question si vous souhaitez on parlait
beaucoup et c'est vrai daniel dannon
mais il était comme moi quoi mais vous
avez progrès lui en cours pour pourquoi
pourquoi pour la bande à gégé j'ai fait
la chirurgie mammaire donc que
l'augmentation mammaire les dents il est
dans la bouche est non la bouche les
oreilles dans la bouche et les yeux
non justement n'ont en effet plus que
toi
mais attend des excuses excusez moi mais
quand vous achetez une deux chevaux fera
jamais une série avait
[Applaudissements]
oui mes deux chevaux ça fait des
kilomètres ma chérie le plus anglais
très bon bien sûr la jeune fille aurélie
d'autres non à la base elle était très
jolie ses deux filles mais je pense
qu'avec le temps les réseaux sociaux la
télé réalité elle s'est trouvé des
problèmes qu'elle n'avait pas le petit
truc sur le nez moi je le vois pas elle
est super jolie ça devient maintenant
une obsession pour elle et c'est plus
quelque chose de naturel faut savoir
avoir des limites est vraiment changer
quelque chose qu'on veut apparemment
alors ce que disent les docteurs c'est
que les gens qui commençait comme les
tatouages quand on commence on a du mal
à s'arrêter c'est vrai que va pas se
mentir
de temps en temps vous vous et vous y
retourner mais ça parce que vous ça vous
plaît un entretien c'est que ça yahiaoui
mais attention c'est pas de la chirurgie
moi je fais pas la charge est lourde
fait beaucoup de piqûres beaucoup
d'injection de choses comme ça
continuera c'est vrai que moi j'ai
refait aussi ma poitrine j'ai refait
j'ai fait une liposuccion sa vraie vie
tu vas passer sur le billard plusieurs
fois je l'assumé parce que j'ai 38 ans
je n'ai pas 20 ans c'est vrai donc
j'estime qu'à mon âge je peux me le
permettre et ensuite je me sens mieux
dans ma peau j'ai jamais été aussi bien
un jour que j'ai refait ma poitrine me
sentir épanouie et heureuse ne bougeait
pas dans un instant on aura des images
geronzi ces éléments l'elysée m'a tuer
est-ce que vous vous pourriez avoir
recours à la chirurgie esthétique est ce
que c'est un sujet dont on parle dans
votre milieu
dans le milieu du handicap oui il ya des
personnes qui je connais des personnes
qui songent à faire de la chirurgie
esthétique pour se sentir mieux dans
leur corps pour des raisons médicales
ouais c'est vrai que ça peut aider et
personnellement moi je ne souhaiterais
pas faire de la chirurgie esthétique
parce que je m'accepte comme je suis et
j'ai pas besoin de changer mon corps
après je peux comprendre tout à fait
qu'il ya des gens qui va lui changer
leur corps pour pour mon rythme pour
accueillir tout à fait vrai le problème
c'est qu il y ait des dérapages
évidemment mais ce qui ce qui semble
influencer les jeunes c'est les fameux
filtre snapshot plus en plus de jeunes
veulent ressembler à l'image qu'ils ont
sur leur téléphone qui n'est pas réel
rappelle et regardez moi ces enfants
c'est trop mignon j'ai des petites
oreilles en apparence inoffensif et
drôle ils ont en réalité modifier nos
critères de beauté plage est là pour
tout six plages et des petites taches de
rousseur partout qui ont été rajoutés et
et la laissera est gonflé aussi si on
enlève
[Musique]
c'est horrible cette sensation pénible
tous rethel la jeune génération a cédé à
la tentation du bistouri
alors là c'est vrai qu'avec eux on est
quand même mieux avec le film que sont
le filtre évidemment miles ah ben moi
c'est c'est une passion les filles
feront pas se mentir c'est vrai là
dessus donc pas leur donner tort ils ont
raison les filtres c'est ça change une
personnelle prend sa chance d'un visage
tout de suite on se dit ouah c'est
génial et on n'arrive plus à prêt à se
taper ou à 100 sans filtre on n'y arrive
plus et moi sur snap quand je le fais
c'est c'est un enfer pour moi c'est une
souffrance parce qu'on voit son vrai
quand on se trouve forcément moche quoi
donc c'est heureux car je reconnais que
là dessus il y avait des risques
il ya quand même deux choses
scandaleuses que j'aurai un peu évoquée
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
banalisation de la chirurgie est quand
même un acte chirurgical se dire qu'il
ya des risques et c'est pas n'importe
quoi et deuxième chose qu'ils aiment
beaucoup de médecins aujourd'hui je suis
deuxième à gali mais via des gens télé
réalité qui se font une espèce de
publicité clandestine faut quand même
rappeler que les médecins n'ont pas le
droit de faire de publicité et
qu'aujourd'hui on a des cliniques qui
apparaissent des médecins qui
apparaissent docteur miami et travail
tralala aujourd'hui un commerce un
business qui est vraiment très
dangereuse qui fait aussi beaucoup de
charlatans qui commence un petit peu à
voir le jour la médecine esthétique
pareil c'est pas anodin de se faire une
piqûre de botox autre chose c'est pas
anodin il peut y avoir des risques aussi
donc ça c'est vrai nom c'est deux choses
sur lesquelles chaude à l'app store chez
morandini a eu un jeune homme qui était
reçue qui veut ressembler ou qui
ressemble un peu à ken c'est vrai que
moi je doute perso qui était presque
mieux avant et que maintenant regarder
alors j'ai fait une biche et tommy donc
voilà ce qu'on nomme michel tomi en fait
on enlève les boules de bichat qu'on a à
chaque le chaque côté des joues ouais ça
fleurit de co2 de creuser les jours ce
sera exactement
d'accord j'ai fait une déposition du
coup et unis position des joues 19 ans
oui et j'ai fait une position des
pectoraux et
du ventre et les abdos aussi les abdos
vous avez fait quoi sur les abdos
michigan nominal donc en fait on
récupère les graisses du côté et on se
les uns plantes sur les abdominaux
après j'ai juste en retirer des choses
justes retire la grèce il ya des
méthodes
voilà où on implante par exemple des
justes quand on a 18 ans pourquoi pour
avoir des abdos ont fait pas de sport
alors ça c'est une bonne remarque alors
moi je vous dis je vous fais une
confidence je me suis renseigné sur dfa
la fameuse abdou plastique problème
c'est que on vous prend des bouts de
graisse et on met des petits pâtés là
alors vivement
evènement c'est pas mal mais quand vous
touchez c'est dégueulasse avec l'elysée
mois et commence a dit que que vous y
pensiez vous que vous l'ayez fait à la
limite je tiens non mais il pense que
c'est un problème mais on est un bébé on
n'est pas encore construit à cet âge là
moi y'a un truc qui me choque dans la
chirurgie esthétique c'est pas nous à
notre âge 30 35
voilà on va se faire des petits trucs
pour sentir mieux c'est normal et c'est
pas grave tout nous on peut l'entendre
moi ce qui me dérange c'est quand on
essaye de ressembler à quelqu'un parce
que c'est ça si c'est un problème pour
l'usinage par exemple les gens mais un
problème pour lui si je ne juge pas du
tout ce que je vous dis c'est que moi en
tant que maman je réfléchis en tant que
maman j'ai un garçon qui va avoir 18 ans
si dans un an il avait autant de trucs à
cléré envie de se refaire mais je serai
malheureuse pour lui parce que je me
dirais qu est-ce que j'ai mal fait
pourquoi qui se détestent autant voilà
tout simplement pas ou qu'il ait autant
envie de ressembler à quelqu'un d'autre
voilà bien un mot non mais maintenant
c'est ça c'est oui ou non mais c 'est la
tendance c'est que les chirurgiens
disent ils arrivent et ils disent je
veux les seins de nabila les faisans kim
kardashian sa garde à silvère michard
nisation de la société je voudrais juste
dire parce que ça me fait de la peine
magali moi c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup et en fait dans sa tête et dans
la tête de plein le bonheur est synonyme
de beauté je suis désolé marilyn monroe
était la fille la plus belle du monde et
ça a été la plus mal à retrouver son et
marées il ça n'a rien à voir et voilà la
bouteille n'est pas forcément
bon alors on va passer au togo nettement
moi je n'oserais jamais les personnes
qui ont envie de changer clients légers
pas justifié mais alors les voyais même
pas leur bouche qui est malheureux doit
honnêtement si l'on lui de le faire moi
j'ai pas de problème avec tout ce qui se
passe dans les ceux qui vont se faire
opérer en dehors de la france que c'est
moins cher dans des conditions précaires
ça c'est à mon avis c'est un fléau mais
bon chacun fait comme il veut et leurs
enfants parce que leurs enfants leurs
ressources leur ont pas de problème
oui oui je voulais juste rajouter que on
est tellement dans une société de
paraître où le paraître est tellement
important du coup ça nous pousse à la
consommation aussi vis-à-vis de tout ce
qui est chirurgie esthétique et ses
textes à et du coup mais finalement tout
le monde se ressemble
ça c'est vrai c'est terrible mais c'est
du clonage toutes les émissions télé
réalité toutes les petites jeunes de
entre 17 18 24 25
elles ont toutes la même adresse toutes
mes différents lors une allée brutale et
le blues à l'intérieur
sur diversifier ou les professions non
c'est pas vrai jeune arrogant qui se
ressemblent aux émirats gagné 20 mai
niveau a commencé quand elles font
entrer poursuite vous inquiétez pas
aucune d'entre elles ont un camembert
[Applaudissements]